a senior democratic senator has said
that there'll be no enthusiasm for a uk
u.s trade deal in congress if the good
friday agreement is damaged by arguments
over brexit speaking to me a few minutes
ago senator chris murphy said the
special relationship is america's most
important alliance but he warned that
the uk that a failure to reach agreement
over the northern ireland protocol could
affect that bond as well as communities
in northern ireland
we're deeply appreciative of the british
government for hosting so many u.s
members of congress and diplomats
over the course of cop 26 i'm proud of
the progress that was made there this is
obviously the most important alliance
that we have
we obviously have great equities in the
good friday agreement there are
supporters on both sides of the aisle
republicans and democrats in congress
and i think the message is that uh right
now we want to make sure that these
negotiations over the northern ireland
protocol the sort of last stages of
brexit are done in a way that doesn't
compromise the the relative peace and
stability that you see today in and
around belfast you've got a lot of
members of congress who care deeply
about the good friday agreement and
many of us feel that exercising article
16
could plunge
northern ireland into economic chaos
which could lead to political
instability and
we need to press this message
in brussels as well the brussels needs
to come to the table and agree to be
flexible on the implementation of the
protocols but
certainly a lot of american interest in
making sure that we preserve the
foundations of the good friday agreement
of course an element of the good friday
agreement was respect for both
communities and to a certain extent open
borders now
uh brexit is rather different philosophy
from that i mean do you actually think
that brexit is compatible with
preserving the good friday agreement
because it's going to mean isn't it
borders of some kind somewhere which
won't like uh won't go down well with
one of the communities
i i think there's a potential for
the
sort of arrangement between the
britain and the eu to result very
favorably for northern ireland i
understand this is very difficult about
how the checks are done but the extent
northern ireland can have
an ease of trade
both with the rest of britain but also
with the european union puts them you
know in a very unique position i'm
hopeful and expectant that there'll be a
way to work out with europe a system by
which the goods that are going into
northern ireland staying in northern
ireland can be exempt from checks or get
very low level of checks and that a very
small number of goods that may end up in
the european union uh are subject to
those inspections that's a deal i think
that's there for the taking and the
result of that i think could be very
good both economically and politically
for northern ireland when i was there
yesterday the day before you know we
heard about companies that are right now
seeking to locate in and around belfast
because of the ability to be able to
trade um freely from belfast into the
european union and into the rest of uh
that's a problem my hope is that
by the end of the year a deal can be
done but that may work for businesses in
northern ireland but that is the problem
for boris johnson and david frost
because they don't want to see
northern ireland benefiting from still
being part of the single market because
uh that would set back their ideas that
brexit such a good idea
well i i hope that they understand the
unique position that northern ireland is
in there is going to have to be some
special status for northern ireland if
not then you are talking about the
reestablishment of a of a hard border
which
would be bad for northern ireland and i
i think um very bad for the political
process so i don't think there's any way
around
brexit having to result in some kind of
special status for uh for northern
ireland and again i i think that there
needs to be pressure on both sides both
on um
london and on brussels to get that done
how much of a deal breaker do you think
getting this right is for the u.s
congress particularly the house of
representatives i mean
[Music]
we know
i mean and the senate indeed are we
going to see
if
boris johnson makes a mess of this are
we going to see
the us congress effectively saying well
no trade deal with the uk then
i think that's likely i mean i don't
mean to be blunt but i i think if we see
the good friday agreement in jeopardy
there is not going to be
a lot of enthusiasm from the united
states congress on both sides of the
aisle frankly um to move forward on a
trade agreement there is enthusiasm for
a trade agreement but um
boy we have a lot of equities a lot of
history wrapped up in the good friday
agreement and is um you know we've seen
you know a slight uptick in violence and
uh tension in northern ireland we don't
want to see that explode as could be the
case if this
all goes wrong so i'll be there first in
line to support a trade agreement with
britain but for many of us again
republicans and democrats we need to
make sure that um the good friday
agreement process is is unharmed as we
try to figure out the um final stages of
brexit and obviously just finally i do
think that the british government boris
johnson
and david frost have engaged with this
seriously enough yet
oh i i i think they have um and i think
that there's you know a renewed sense of
optimism uh
having been on the ground for a few days
that this can
get done i think europe has been
flexible i think there's a a new
understanding about how to you know
again make sure that you most of
everything that will flow into northern
ireland does so uh without checks or a
minimal number of checks and i hope that
our engagement uh from congress uh and
from the administration uh right now is
going to you know help push this along
there's no reason that a deal can't get
done and my sense is that the british
government is serious about it and my
hope is that the european union is just
as serious about making the compromises
necessary to preserve the good friday
agreement um and um allow for that free
trade of almost all goods uh into
northern ireland and back to
england wales and scotland and just as a
point of information really are you
going to brussels as well to talk to
them about this
um you know we are right up against the
thanksgiving holiday in the states so
i'm going to be heading
back to spend time with family but i'm
going to be actively communicating with
my friends in brussels uh our allies
there to make sure that they
you know are just as willing to be at
the table
compromise in hand uh in the coming
weeks
senator we thank you
for your time for your attention and
also of course happy thanksgiving
thank you very much